[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana analizamos la
izquierda latinoamericana a partir de la
victoria en chile de boris y del
favoritismo de petro en las elecciones
de colombia nos preguntamos si llega una
nueva izquierda a la región y para ello
nos acompañan en este estudio la
periodista chilena independiente paola
martínez infante bienvenida y venía
gracias carlos por la invitación lissl
quirós historiadora profesora de
estudios latinoamericanos en la
universidad de sergi bienvenida
y en dúplex desde la universidad de lynn
jacobo grajales profesor de política
comparada buenos días señor grajales
buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación
moritz petro podemos hablar de una nueva
izquierda en latinoamérica hoy en
primera plana
gabriel boliche es el presidente más
joven de la historia de chile con 36
años con él llega una nueva generación
política joven forjada en las protestas
estudiantiles que define a esta nueva
izquierda en el caso chileno sin duda se
trata de un hito histórico como también
puede ser un hito histórico que el
izquierdista petro llegue al poder en
colombia tras el proceso de
presidenciales que está a punto de
abrirse en el país por primera vez en su
historia democrática a la izquierda
colombiana tiene posibilidades reales de
ganar unas elecciones que supondría este
hecho hoy nos interesamos por realidades
concretas pero también intentamos marcar
trazos comunes hablamos de una nueva
izquierda diferenciada de la bolivariana
o no tanto es una izquierda más
conectada al ecologismo y al feminismo y
menos a venezuela ya cuba
vamos con algunas portadas diario el
mostrador trata en este artículo nuestro
tema de hoy la vuelta de la izquierda
américa latina y se pregunta pero que
izquierda revista semana con el favorito
para las elecciones en colombia pero
gobernaré para todos también este lado
del atlántico los diarios tratan este
asunto del diario la razón en españa'
moritz el espejo en el que se mira la
izquierda d
a latina en bueno para blas podemos
hablar de una nueva izquierda encarnada
en el presidente chileno boris un espejo
para la izquierda en la región no es
mucho decir un espejo para la región hay
que esperar todavía los resultados han a
club ya que hace dos meses está en el
poder lo que sí pienso que sí una nueva
izquierda porque hay diferentes matices
primero la generación muy joven no
quería que pudrirse viene de la calle es
un líder estudiantil del año 2011
durante las protestas las luchas por la
por la educación en chile se forjó
justamente en esa lucha social en la
cual él quiere para el pueblo y no esa
masa amorfa de polio sino que realmente
ese pueblo definido por diferentes
necesidades sociales como el precursor
de cambios profundos en la sociedad para
tener una sociedad más justa y digna en
ese caso yo pienso que sí es una nueva
izquierda porque además hay una fuerte
crítica al discurso de la izquierda
tradicional entonces él se posiciona
justamente con un innovador no como un
mesías atención no es alguien que va a
venir un nombre podéis prudencial que va
a cambiar las cosas no es para el hoy
día vamos a hablar más tarde pero no ha
sido fácil surtir sus primeros dos meses
en el gobierno por diferentes razones
porque la única verdad es la realidad
como decía aristóteles entonces ahí está
un poco tanteando terreno ha tenido que
cambiar algunas cosas que tenía
comisiones bien profundas para poder
alternar ese poder frente a lo que se le
está presentando como país también pero
sí volviendo a la pregunta si es una
nueva izquierda por lo que decía yo por
las generaciones porque son jóvenes que
vienen de la calle de la calle en
sentido desde las luchas sociales por
una parte y sobre todo con algo muy
importante es el feminismo es a esa
paridad también que le ofrece al país y
a la manera de hacer política al que
debe ir esa nueva izquierda ha tomado
más colores que la que se vivió a
comienzos del siglo 21 más banderas en
particular las banderas verdes del
ecologismo y moradas del feminismo
tienen un rol protagonista
esto es todo debido a un cambio de
generación lissl o hay que buscar otras
razones
en un cambio de generación y creo que
también es un cambio histórico hay
evoluciones históricas y efectivamente
no se puede hablar de una izquierda
latinoamericana pero tampoco se podía
hablar de una izquierda latinoamericana
en los años 60 o 70 es decir que ya él
siempre los grupos sociales son grupos
sociales que tienen diferentes agendas
políticas y ahora lo que sucede me
parece es que los grupos minorizados que
anteriormente en la historia de américa
latina- no estaban tan presentes ahora
alzan la voz y salen a hacer sus
reivindicaciones de manera pública y
dentro de este sistema político y eso lo
podemos ver de los movimientos
feministas pero también todas las
minorías sociales como sucede en chile
con los mapuches los indígenas en perú
también y toda la izquierda
latinoamericana hoy día se ha renovado
también por esa presencia de esos grupos
minorizados que son las mujeres los
indígenas
que los vemos más presentes y que a
partir de estos últimos de este siglo ya
es quieren party si quieren verdaderos
cambios en la política y sobre todo en
temas de derechos puesto que lo que
sucede es que la izquierda había de
alguna manera dejado un poco de lado
estas esos problemas que conciernen a la
mayoría a millones de personas desde la
universidad de lille jacobo grajales
profesor de política comparada señor
grajales vamos con otro país todos los
sondeos apuntan al izquierdista petro
que ganará las elecciones en colombia
como favorito digamos que los sondeos lo
que indican es que seguramente gustavo
petro llegará primero en la en la
primera vuelta si delante del candidato
de la derecha federico gutiérrez y
seguramente también delante de los
candidatos del centro
sin embargo lo que no sabemos es cuáles
serán los resultados de la segunda
vuelta puesto que la posibilidad de que
haya un frente anti petro como lo hubo
en las elecciones del 2018 sigue siendo
importante ahí puede haber una capacidad
sobre todo de un candidato del centro de
movilizar tanto los votantes del centro
como los de la derecha contra la idea
contra el proyecto de gobierno de
gustavo petro y del pacto histórico si
logra vencer al bloque anti petro que
significaría su victoria en la historia
contemporánea del país una victoria
gustavo petro en colombia sería algo
histórico para el país puesto que sería
el primer gobierno de izquierda en la
historia de colombia sería también una
victoria
un evento histórico en la región porque
colombia históricamente es un país muy
anclado hasta la derecha es un es un eje
de la influencia de eeuu en el
continente es un eje de la política
conservadora en el continente lo ha sido
estos últimos años sin embargo me parece
también que sería
habría que
matizar un poco el significado de esta
victoria porque gustavo petro no
tendrías y si llegase a ser presidente
no tendrían una mayoría en el congreso
colombiano en el senado y en la cámara
de representantes entonces necesitaría
crear unas alianzas en una suerte de
frente amplio con otros partidos y
seguramente con el partido liberal que
es un partido que digamos es muy es muy
versátil y se puede aliar porque así con
que con cualquier otra
formación política en colombia y esta
alianza con otros partidos obviamente lo
llevaría a moderar muchísimo su programa
de gobierno vamos de un país a otro
intentando buscar denominadores comunes
o no como están siempre vamos de
colombia ahora a chile en el caso
chileno como éste haciendo en paola los
primeros pasos de boliche en el poder no
ha sido fácil hay dos cosas importantes
que señalar una es de dónde viene la
elección de voyage del estadio social
chileno en 2019 cierto donde el pueblo
se despierta para lo se llamaba chile
despertó y hacen una crítica absoluta y
acérrima al modelo neoliberal que perona
va desde los años de la dictadura cierto
por una parte entonces cuando él llega
al poder llega con muchas expectativas
como yo lo decía anteriormente sin
embargo se ha topado con dificultades
una porque por una parte la derecha
chilena no bajar gobernar de manera tan
fácil porque tiene un programa social
que es radical y quien que habla en
radicalismo es darle una vida digna a
las personas sólo en cuatro días ya una
aberración pensar que una idea extrema
es darle una vía justa a la gente por
una parte ha tenido que enfrentarse al
conflicto la araucanía de nuevo con él
con el pueblo mapuche ha tenido que
también
decretar el estado de excepción que
anteriormente cuando piñera lo había
hecho había sido los principales
críticos justamente de esas medidas y se
da cuenta efectivamente que el ejercicio
del poder es tener las ideas que son
unas ideas muy nobles para el pueblo
chileno por otra parte es posicionarse
frente a dos meses en el poder en la
cual la sociedad chilena hoy día está
con muchas expectativas y los problemas
reales que están presentes la sociedad
el caso migratorio también que es un
tema muy importante que no fue resuelto
por piñera en el gobierno anterior
entonces hereda de dos conflictos
mayores la crisis migratoria y también
el conflicto en araucanía entonces los
primeros 60 días digamos del gobierno
han sido complejos porque ha tenido que
adaptar conciliar también a ojo que era
una persona que estaba muy abierta al
diálogo si bien es cierto tiene un
programa que es radical en su manera de
proponer un cambio social estructural y
de envergadura del país está muy abierto
al diálogo y sabe que todo lo que va a
llevar a cabo e incluso esta nueva
constitución que ese resto que ya ha
entregado el borrador que será puesta a
plebiscito en septiembre debe con un
consenso también de diferentes actores
que existen en la sociedad chilena lo
que si queremos una diferencia muy clara
con esta nueva izquierda es su relación
con venezuela y con cuba vamos a invadir
si lo hemos visto muy claramente no se
posicionó directamente como un hace con
un asiduo crítica digamos al bolivarismo
también decir que él no quería este
autoritarismo en que o se había impuesto
justamente el chavismo una parte del
nuevo maduro lo criticó abiertamente a
través de twitter después que un informe
de derechos humanos justamente llevado
por basile que el alta con visera
derechos humanos el afirma y dice que
efectivamente en venezuela se han
violado derechos humanos y critica
abiertamente según en autoritario
entonces él se desprende un poco de esa
izquierda que es autoritaria que es
populista también y quiere presentar un
nuevo modelo y además desmarcarse cuesta
también la famosa crítica veces de la
derecha hacia la izquierda
latinoamericana de relacionarlo con
venezuela y con cuba también lo estamos
viendo en otros países no siempre ese es
el argumento para desprestigiar
la nueva izquierda latinoamericana es
asociar la con venezuela y con cuba pero
definitivamente todos los gobiernos
incluyendo por ejemplo el de pedro
castillo se han solidarizado no sans por
por razones obvias no no apoyan y no
están en esa relación no estás formando
un bloque digamos
bolivariano podríamos decir como a
finales del siglo 20 entonces lo que
creo es que está como lo decía paola es
difícil para esta nueva izquierda que
accedió al poder en todo caso como en el
caso de boris en perú es similar este
pedro castillo sino el poder
prácticamente ya va a ser un año nueve
meses y no ha podido no ha podido poner
en acción el plan de gobierno ya ha
tenido cuatro cambios de gobierno se ha
puesto en
está todavía en mucha mucha atención en
el congreso porque no hay una mayoría
para poder gobernar y tiene que estar en
ese proceso como lo dijo el invitado
también de alianzas de frentes de
organización entonces es mucho trabajo
finalmente para encontrar una alianza
que le permitan poner en práctica el
el programa y entre tanto el pedido de
los millones de los millones de personas
que están esperando el cambio es muy
fuerte entonces hay esa atención
constante en estos gobiernos que hace
pensar en todo caso en perú o como en el
caso de chile y la auracanía es que los
movimientos sociales se vuelvan a
activar y que eso suscite un clima un
poco de violencia nos van a permitir que
hagamos en este punto una breve pausa
pero seguimos de inmediato analizando la
izquierda latinoamericana a partir de la
victoria de boris y del favoritismo de
petro en colombia hasta ahora
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semana de france 24 sobre el éxodo miles
de personas cada año se ven obligadas al
éxodo a huir de sus países en busca de
una vida mejor llevamos una mirada
humana a la migración masiva en américa
latina y en el resto del mundo
acompáñenme inmigrantes por france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]
france24 la economía día a día
liberté égalité actuality en primera
plana esta semana analizando la nueva
izquierda latinoamericana a partir de la
victoria de boris en sigue también del
favoritismo de petro en colombia
intentamos mirar si hay denominadores en
común pero como decía él y se él justo
antes de irnos a la pausa tampoco se
puede analizar todo como una como un
bloque monolítico no hay diferencias una
de las cosas que se incorpora moritz es
el eco de los movimientos sociales no ha
totalmente de hecho justamente en este
ello social como lo mencioné
anteriormente en 2019 abrió esa puerta
de las reivindicaciones de la sociedad
chilena
los problemáticas existían desde siempre
pero a partir de 2019 la gente expresa
libremente que no quieren más abuso que
el modelo tal como fue establecido basta
y genera desigualdad genera indignidad
también nadó de condiciones de vida
indignas también y yo me acuerdo que en
ese mismo momento cuando chile estalla
cuando chile despierta en ecuador hubo
movimientos sociales los bolivianos se
despertaron también y sintieron que la
reivindicación social si bien cada país
la sociedad tiene sus particularidades
había un denominador común no queremos
más este modelo que nos aplasta no
queremos más este capitalismo que nos
aplasta entonces en ese aspecto
evidentemente hay un denominador común y
por supuesto después cada gobierno cada
política estatal debe adaptar esas
reivindicaciones generales a de justicia
social son derechos universales hay que
saberlo derecho a la educación derecho a
la salud derecho a una vida digna son
cosas universales cada país y cada
política adapta según las realidades
locales vamos a irnos con el profesor
jacobo grajales de la universidad de
lynn para tratar también poner el foco
sobre el caso colombiano en que se basa
profesor graham grajales en qué se basa
este auge de intención de voto de petro
en colombia si pudiésemos resumirlo en
dos o tres razones básicas yo
y diría primero que todo que existe un
contexto económico y social y un
contexto económico de crisis con
obviamente los resultados de la pandemia
pero también una una crisis más general
de la economía colombiana que se vive
desde incluso antes de la pandemia del
del cobi
hoy hoy en día por ejemplo en colombia
se vive con una inflación en el mes de
abril alcanzó a más de 9 por ciento el
desplome de la tasa de cambio del peso
con respecto a divisas internacionales
sobre todo el dólar también ha
encarecido muchísimo los bienes de
consumo que en gran parte son importados
entonces también es una es una crisis
del modelo económico colombiano existe
también una situación
de protesta social que comenzó desde
incluso antes de la pandemia pero que ha
venido creciendo muchísimo después de la
pandemia con las grandes manifestaciones
que
tuvieron lugar el año pasado y yo diría
también que el populismo de derecha que
logró gobernar a colombia durante los 8
años del mandato de álvaro uribe y que
logró poner de nuevo un presidente en el
2018 con el actual presidente iván duque
que se ha venido agotando la derecha se
ve reducida a un electorado muy muy muy
pequeño con respecto al
electorado de distintas clases sociales
que logró en su tiempo movilizar álvaro
uribe muy interesante y se hablaba antes
paola de los movimientos sociales no sé
si la convicción de que los momentos
sociales deben jugar un rol protagonista
en la democracia quizá ese sea la mayor
incorporación el mayor denominador común
de la nueva izquierda lo que podemos
entender como nueva izquierda
absolutamente creo que no es solamente
que se les haya dado ese espacio es que
lo han ganado en las calles lo han
ganado por sus movilizaciones sus luchas
y definitivamente y olvidaba y creo que
hay que esos grupos minorizados están
tomando un rol protagónico
los grupos los pueblos originarios pero
también las comunidades afro
latinoamericanas y es el caso en
colombia que viven en situaciones de
precariedad muy fuertes y entonces están
muy activas y eso a pesar y en la
crítica y en eso estoy de acuerdo con
paola que hay una crítica de todo el
sistema político en su globalidad creo
que vemos por todos en todos los casos
una crítica muy fuerte a cómo está
organizado el sistema político en torno
a los temas de corrupción que es
generalizado en todos los países vamos a
ver y de reforma de este sistema a
través en particular de la reforma de la
constitución todos los países y que se
ya sea en chile en perú la propuesta es
de formar una nueva constitución una
constitución que sea en algunos casos
plurinacional es decir que tome en
cuenta
la diversidad de estos pueblos que
forman conforman estas naciones y que se
organicen muchísimo mejor de manera
afirmada los derechos de todos de todos
y de todas y todos le quería preguntar
al profesor
jacobo grajales desde la universidad de
lille en el caso colombiano volvemos hay
miedo a petro y sectores del país hacia
qué exactamente es decir se agita el
discurso de venezuela también
hay un
discurso anti izquierdista
históricamente muy anclado en la
política colombiana
que tiene que ver obviamente con la
historia de la insurgencia la historia
de la guerrilla pero también ha habido
una movilización muy fuerte de parte de
los medios de comunicación y sobre todo
medios de comunicación que le pertenecen
a grandes actores económicos del país a
conglomerados económicos y que han
utilizado el discurso según el cual
gustavo petro mucho antes de hecho de
que existiese el pacto histórico
llevaba un proyecto político
afín al venezuela por ejemplo
cuba se creó toda una imagen de lo que
la derecha colombiana llama el
castrochavismo es decir como éste está
en esta imagen según la cual colombia
gobernada por la izquierda seguramente
comenzaría a parecerse a venezuela y los
colombianos saben cuáles son las cuál es
la situación en venezuela por ser el
primer país en receptáculos de la
inmigración venezolana entonces está
esta imagen ha sido muy utilizada por
los medios de comunicación
y ha logrado hacer cierta mella en la
imagen de la izquierda colombiana el
caso de boris paola también me imagino
que hubo fuertes críticas que se han ido
fuerte y sobre todo durante la campaña
cada vez que él pronuncia la palabra
social o dignidad o estructura el
programa social etcétera era no cuidado
atención nos vamos atrás fue una nueva
venezuela las colas nos esperan etcétera
y no olvidemos también que éste tiene
también el recuerdo
la unidad popular cuando el antes
vísperas al golpe de estado hay todo un
boicot a la economía y al modelo social
que impone allende justamente para
estabilizar su gobierno y justificar un
golpe de estado entonces hoy día lo que
lo que dice lo que sucede en colombia
muy certero y también sucede enchilados
hay una idea de que todos los programas
sociales están instalando cuidado porque
podemos caer en una inflación extrema
como en venezuela cuidado porque nos
vamos a extreme izar como los
venezolanos cuidado porque las economías
son y es una crítica muy fácil de
justamente los grupos económicos que
tienen el poder desde siempre en la
región no solamente en chile en el que
hay que olvidar que en chile y cinco
féminas que tienen el 30 por ciento del
producto interno nacional entonces esa
gente teme así que sus privilegios sean
pasados a llevar o bien con esa reforma
tributaria que queda ser boris también
puedan ser apabullado o bien dejados de
lado entonces efectivamente hay un miedo
digamos una suerte de fantasma que
circula que todo lo que van a proponer
tengan cuidado porque me den el ejemplo
venezuela
señalando la heterogeneidad de la región
por supuesto si hay algunas
convergencias ideológicas para el
conjunto de la región que pueden
producir beneficios me refiero a vamos
hacia una izquierda que apueste más por
la integración regional tras las
divisiones institucionales como enlace
la que en la oea que hemos tenido los
últimos años decir si quieren izquierda
convencida de que la integración es un
asunto pendiente en américa latina' si
yo pienso que hay hay una parte de la
izquierda y creo que bolita en perú por
ejemplo un grupo como el torno a
verónica mendoza proponen ese tipo no de
brit que son que se inscriben en la
historia de américa latina porque
américa latina es uno de los espacios
regionales donde la circulación de las
ideas de las ideas políticas es fuerte
no es histórica y creo que esta temática
se va a desarrollar va a ir
desarrollándose o sea que si la pregunta
es un poco si el modelo por ejemplo de
bonito puede
extenderse y puede salir de chile creo
que hay muchas convergencias con otras
partes con otras izquierdas el problema
digamos que los vemos es que no hay solo
una izquierda y que ahí es esta tensión
la que estamos viendo en estos momentos
que izquierda va a ser la que se
finalmente se imponga en la región vamos
a hablar de esas izquierdas comparadas
también con el profesor grajales porque
ideológicamente profesor petro es más
cercano a una nueva generación de
izquierdas como boris y principios
ecofeministas o más bien a otro corte de
generación como hablo en méxico o el
correísmo
gustavo petro historia y también
históricamente viene de una matriz de la
izquierda latinoamericana
qué es la izquierda de los años 90 y
2000 de la de la de la ola de los
gobiernos de izquierda sin embargo
durante los últimos años por lo menos
por lo menos desde el 2016 el que es el
año del acuerdo de paz en colombia
la izquierda colombiana ha hecho muchos
esfuerzos para abrirse hacia otras
temáticas temáticas de defensa del
territorio de defensa de las identidades
plurales de la ecología del feminismo se
ha acercado mucho más a esta esta nueva
ola de izquierda que vemos hoy en día en
américa latina' encarnada pues por el
por la victoria
de la izquierda en chile
otro elemento es que su fórmula de
vicepresidencia francia márquez es una
imagen
paradigmática de lo que es la fuerza de
los movimientos sociales en colombia y
que viene de un movimiento afro
colombiano y ecologista entonces desde
ese punto de vista ha logrado añadirle
una nueva dimensión una dimensión que le
hacía falta a la imagen de gustavo petro
y tal vez seguramente también atraer a
un electorado más joven que tal vez no
se reconocía en esta izquierda histórica
pero que se reconoce mucho más en las
luchas de los movimientos sociales
fíjate interesante lo que nos cuenta
personales como petro incorpora a
francia market que es un poco lo de los
nuevos movimientos para hacer un ticket
sí sí es un es algo que
está presente es decir los movimientos
sociales
creo que eso responde al hecho de que ya
los partidos tradicionales no tienen una
gran acogida en las poblaciones
latinoamericanas hay una crítica muy
importante a esos a esos partidos como
como que forman parte del sistema
político corrupto y que ha sido
totalmente deficiente en estos últimos
tiempos y que al contrario los
movimientos sociales son mucho más
innovadores es definitivamente también
son mucho más flexibles son mucho más
están mucho más dinámicos y entonces eso
está pensando en la composición hoy día
de la recomposición más bien del
panorama político latinoamericano y no
se puede hoy día pensar por ejemplo en
tener planchas de gobierno de propuestas
sin mujeres sin representantes de las
poblaciones minorizadas afro
latinoamericanas en general e indígenas
etcétera entonces eso ya no se puede ver
como antes como antes y eso es una
ruptura última frase para que me quede
nosotros abiertos y muy exigentes
conciliar un estado de bienestar una
democratización absoluta y más encima
llevar a cabo todo un movimiento
feminista y también de calentamiento
global y hacer por el clima es un gran
desafío que no solamente bonito lo
tienes y que todas las izquierdas que
están en el poder hoy día en américa
latina pues muchísimas gracias
paola y jaco por habernos acompañado hoy
analizando lo que es la izquierda
latinoamericana esa nueva izquierda y
como se conjuga con la más tradicional e
a todos ustedes le esperamos aquí en
primera plana la próxima semana gracias
[Música]